[موسيقى]
كانت هناك منافسة وظيفية لأول
مرة بين البيض والسود ، وقد أدى هذا إلى
إحباط الكثير من البيض ،
مثل ألونزو هيرندون ، مما أدى إلى
إحباط
البيض لأنه أصبح هناك هذا النوع من
طبقة النخبة الاجتماعية من السود الذين كان أداءهم
جيدًا  من بعض
[الموسيقى
] البيضاء ، أجريت مقابلة مع امرأة ذات مرة مع امرأة بيضاء
نشأت في وسط مدينة
أتلانتا وكانت تبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات في ذلك
الوقت وأخبرتني ولن أنسى أبدًا
كيف
استيقظت في
تلك الليلة  وعرفت فقط أن شيئًا ما
كان في الهواء لأنها شعرت بتوتر
في الهواء ورأت
والدتها وأختها تصليان بجانب
لافتة النافذة
وذهبت وانضممت
إليهما ونظرت إلى الخارج وكان هناك
عمود إنارة ومن عمود الإنارة
تم شنق رجل أسود وكان جسده
مثقوبًا بالرصاص وسط مدينة
أتلانتا
في أتلانتا ، كانت هناك مصاعد
منفصلة لأجزاء منفصلة بالأبيض والأسود
من المقبرة للأجزاء المنفصلة بالأبيض والأسود
من الترام.  أو
الأناجيل المنفصلة بالأبيض والأسود في
قاعة المحكمة التي ستقسم عليها
بعبارة أخرى ، تم فصل كل جزء من الحياة عن
طريق مطاعم العرق ، ودورات المياه كل شيء
يقوم بحملات سياسية يعتقد الكثير من
المرشحين أنه
إذا كانوا أكثر عنصرية من المرشح الآخر ،
فإنهم سيحصلون على المزيد من البيض
تصويتات وهكذا كان لديك الكثير من
الخطاب العنصري فقط ، حيث نشرت صحيفتان
قصصًا غير صحيحة عن
الرجال السود والملح والنساء البيض.